this morning we're sharing an exclusive
interview with the lead scientist behind
a major breakthrough in transplant
surgery something we told you about
yesterday it could offer a lifeline to
the one to the almost 100 000 americans
waiting for a kidney 12 people a day die
in the u.s waiting for a kidney
transplant but now for the first time
surgeons at nyu langone transplant
institute successfully transplanted a
genetically modified pig kidney into the
human body our chief medical
correspondent dr john lepuc got a first
look at this experimental procedure
are you thinking this is science fiction
or do you think oh yeah of course that's
what we do now it doesn't seem
futuristic it seems like the future's
here now dr robert montgomery and his
team at nyu langone's transplant
institute have done something that's
never been done before successfully
transplant a non-human kidney into a
human being the human immune system
rejects organs from animals but dr
montgomery and his team genetically
modified a pig kidney to make it more
compatible so we came up with this idea
of testing it first in someone who is
recently deceased but is being
maintained on a ventilator the family
consented and donated the body for this
study they felt really strongly that
this would be something that she would
want what was said in the operating room
we had a moment of silence for the
decedent and the family who made this
incredible decision before this first
attempt nyu created a new board
consulting with religious and legal
experts and with bioethicists like dr
art kaplan who heads the medical
center's ethics division do you have any
second thoughts whatsoever that this was
the right thing to do ethically i think
we should be doing it more often what we
have here is absolute certification of
death complete volunteerism on the part
of the people involved in the experiment
with permission and enthusiasm that they
want to help the researchers connected
the pig's kidney above the thigh of the
recipient outside the body so they could
see and test it the kidney turned a
beautiful pink color we were sort of
taking in what we were looking at
which was incredible it was a kidney
that was immediately functioning without
genetic modification a transplanted pig
kidney would likely have been rejected
within minutes
this kidney worked perfectly for 54
hours before being disconnected what
could it mean it could mean that no one
will need to die waiting for an organ
anymore i think it will be something
that you know eventually will be
perfected to the point where it'll be an
alternative to a human organ and for dr
montgomery this is personal he knows all
too well how it feels to wait for a
donor organ the study occurred five days
after the third anniversary of my heart
transplant it was a very emotional
moment
in
time just the fact that you know i was
able to be here
to do this work
is both humbling and it just makes the
whole thing
just feel more important
early days for a new approach that could
save thousands of lives for cbs mornings
i'm dr john lepuc in new york city
uh really cool john family john lapoop
thought twist that the doctor himself
had had to have a life-saving uh surgery
john lepuc would be with us but he had
surgery today he's an opera he's in the
operating room this morning but what an
incredible story when you hear about pig
kidney at first i went uh you need to
but then your hair could save your life
you go
oink oink we need to
stop calling it a pig kidney as soon as
it's suitable for the human body it's
just a kidney period okay the pig but
this really can't be life-changing
actually my my wife's cousin alan is
waiting for a kidney treatment right now
can't find one a lot of americans are in
that situation and if the research is
successful it could not only be kidneys
but lungs hearts other parts of the body
um you know you can save a hundred
thousand lives a year yeah these type of
medical breakthroughs are modern day
miracles that's for sure